[Musique]
pour la première fois en 70 ans les
Britanniques se sont réveillés ce matin
avec un autre monarque que la reine
Elizabeth II qui a régné pendant un peu
plus de 70 ans vous voyez des images de
Charles le roi Charles prenant un bain
de foule devant Buckingham Palace à
Londres avec la reine consort donc ça
conjointe Camila sa femme qui devient
donc reine-consor Charles c'est Charles
III le fils d'Elizabeth II qui va
prononcer dans une demi-heure son
premier discours à titre de roi
d'Angleterre il a quitté ce matin le
château de Balmoral en direction de
Londres où il est allé au palais de
Buckingham comme vous le voyez il est
entré avec sa conjointe dans le palais
de Buckingham il présentera donc sur le
coup de 13h son premier discours c'est
un moment auquel il se prépare depuis sa
naissance il y a 73 ans bon début
d'après-midi bienvenue à cette émission
spéciale du service de l'information de
Radio-Canada sur le premier discours du
prince voilà premier lapsus du roi
Charles III nous vous présenterons c'est
allocution en direct sur le coup de 13
heures d'ici là deux spécialistes de la
monarchie m'accompagne Estelle
Boutillier et Benoît Pelletier qui est
professeur titulaire en droit
constitutionnel à l'Université d'Ottawa
je vous salue Estelle et Benoît merci
d'être avec nous cet après-midi et nous
allons aller en direct de Londres
retrouver notre envoyé spécial Catherine
Gauthier qui est à quelques maîtres du
palais de Buckingham Catherine
parlez-moi de l'ambiance parce qu'on
voit derrière vous des dizaines sinon
des centaines ou des milliers de
personnes qui se sont massées près de la
clôture du palais de Buckingham pour
rendre hommage à la reine Élisabeth II
pour rendre hommage à la reine
effectivement Elisabeth II mais
Sébastien pour voir aussi le nouveau roi
Charles III qui vient de passer tout
juste ici derrière nous à quelques
quelques dizaines de mètres il y a quoi
à peu près 5 minutes donc il vient de
quitter bookingham Palace et il était
arrivé un petit peu plus tôt aujourd'hui
à son arrivée il a pris ce bain de foule
comme vous l'avez dit d'entrée de jeu le
drapeau qui avait été mis en berne après
la mort de la reine Elizabeth II a été
descendu et on a remis en haut du mât le
drapeau royal on l'appelle Royal Stander
donc le drapeau de la famille royale
finalement parce que le nouveau roi
était arrivé à bockingham Palace donc
effectivement depuis ce matin on est ici
très tôt Sébastian est arrivé au début
du jour et puis je vous dirais qu'il y a
des milliers et des milliers de
personnes qui défellent ici depuis le
début de la journée c'était le cas hier
aussi des gens qui ont fait parfois
plusieurs
kilomètres qui ont franchi plusieurs
kilomètres pour venir rendre hommage à
la reine pour déposer des germes de
fleurs Sébastien les gens font la file
font une longue file qui fait plusieurs
coins de rue tranquillement plusieurs le
font en silence pour pouvoir aller
déposer justement la gerbe de fleurs et
se recueillir à la mémoire de la reine
Elisabeth II on a entendu les cloches
sonner ce matin westmins toaby on a
aussi entendu les 96 coups de canon pour
souligner que la reine s'était éteinte à
96 ans alors une ambiance je vous dirais
évidemment de recueillement quand on
pense au départ de la reine mais aussi
assez festif quand on pense à cette
transition à cette arrivée en fait du
nouveau roi Charles III la foule
spontanément entonné le God Save de King
pour ce qu'on s'habitue aussi à ça
parlez-nous Catherine de ce discours
attendu parce que c'est la première fois
qu'on va Charles en tant que roi
c'est un discours qui a été enregistré
ici à bockingham Palace un petit peu
plus tôt aujourd'hui donc à son arrivée
parce qu'il a quitté Balmoral ce matin
est arrivé en fin de matinée ici déjà au
travail effectivement un discours qui
est attendu on sait que la situation
actuelle en Grande-Bretagne n'est pas
facile l'inflation explose les
Britanniques ont hâte d'entendre
justement ce premier discours à la
nation donc qui sera télévisé dans moins
d'une heure il a aussi rencontré on l'a
vu elle aussi arriver la nouvelle
Première ministre britannique l'histoire
qui est venu le rencontrer ici ça a duré
au moins une heure cette rencontre là si
on se fait à l'arrivée au départ de la
première ministre donc déjà beaucoup de
travail alors que le deuil lui il est
commencé bien sûr et on en a pour
plusieurs jours Sébastien bon on
commence le deuil la dépouille de la
reine est encore à Balmoral devrait
arriver au cours des prochains jours il
y aura chapelle ardent ici pour ses
proches ensuite le cortège va aller
jusqu'à Westminster Hall où là il y aura
chapelle ardente pour les membres du
public et s'il y a des milliers de
personnes ici pour venir juste déposer
des gerbes de fleurs et se recueillir
imaginer lors de cette chapelle ardente
à quelques coins de rue d'ici à Londres
et vont suivre bien sûr ensuite les
funérailles de la Reine Elisabeth dans
une dizaine de jours parce qu'il y a
tout un calendrier très précis jour par
jour à la suite du décès de la reine qui
nous mène probablement à dimanche poste
dimanche qui vient mais l'autre dimanche
ou le lundi suivant pour les funérailles
nationales de la reine d'Angleterre
Catherine merci beaucoup je sais que
vous avez pas beaucoup dormi parce qu'on
vous avait dépêché en toute hâte à
Londres merci d'avoir pris quelques
minutes avec nous aujourd'hui
au plaisir
j'ai le plaisir de retrouver Estelle
Boutillier spécialiste de la monarchie
britannique et Benoît Pelletier
professeur titulaire en droit
constitutionnel à la Faculté de droit de
l'Université de tawa qui vont
m'accompagner pour leur ennemi à venir à
vous deux bons début d'après-midi
bonjour madame Boutier d'abord je
commencerai par vous sur le discours de
Charles c'est un moment important parce
que il peut donner le ton à son règne
madame Bouty c'est ce qu'on prévoit je
suis persuadée que dans un premier temps
il va rendre hommage à la reine sa mère
et par la suite il va donner
c'est les grandes lignes de ce qu'il
aimerait accomplir pendant son règne
évidemment on va parler fort probable du
commonwears de sa fort probable de sa
restructuration on va parler aussi
d'économie ça c'est certain
d'environnement
son intérêt pour
les autres tonnes à travers le monde
c'est important aussi alors j'ai
l'impression que là il va donner les
grandes lignes de ce qu'il aimerait
faire pendant ces années de règles et en
même temps
préparer
leur règne suivant parce qu'on sait bon
le prince Charles déjà 73 ans vous
parlez d'un roi de transition où si je
vous ai bien entendu et ça c'est pour
moi ça va être un roi et c'est sur la
transition peut durer 15 ou 20 ans mais
ils ont une longévité dans cette famille
là en passant oui il reste que oui c'est
sûr dans 20 ans Charles le roi Charles
n'aura que 93 ans mais il reste que
il sait très bien que même si décédait
dans une vingtaine d'années le prince
William
accèderait au trône à 60 ans parce qu'il
vient tout juste d'avoir 40 ans donc
je crois que il va donner les grandes
lignes de ce qu'il veut accomplir
pendant son règne et mais le commonweal
je suis convaincu vont ils vont en
parler ça c'est à peu près certain
Benoît est-ce que l'arrivée d'un nouveau
roi change notre relation par rapport à
la monarchie britannique ben non pas en
soi plus qu'il y a une continuité sur le
plan juridique et sur le plan
constitutionnel et également sur le plan
politique ce qui risque de changer
cependant et ça on va le voir au cours
des prochains mois c'est peut-être une
remise en question qui lui aura dans
certains milieux et dans certains pays
dont Charles et le roi une remise en
question de la monarchie elle-même et là
je dois vous dire que pour moi ça peut
avoir avec la personnalité de Charles ça
plus avoir avec le fait que ils se
mettent deux incarnait la monarchie
d'une façon
excellente comme on le sait
instaurer la monarchie comme étant un
principe politique important et là il y
a peut-être des gens qui considèrent que
la monarchie consternelle est dépassée
rendu en 2022 il y a pas des pays où
comme la Barbade qui s'est affranchi la
monarchie récemment vous pensez vous
donc que le le transfert de pouvoir si
on veut pour ressusciter même au Canada
ce type de débat absolument d'abord il
risque d'y avoir un effet domino enfin
une prédiction c'est pas une prévision
mais il réservoir un effet domino en
sens où si dans certains pays il y a un
débat sur l'avenir de la monarchie je
pense à l'Australie je pense à la
Nouvelle-Zélande et ainsi de suite il
est possible que les Canadiens se disent
mais pourquoi nous nous n'aurions pas
nous aussi ce débat là
et donc ça veut dire que le Canada ne
s'apprend peut-être pas au débat sur sûr
le sort de la monarchie
constitutionnelle là ici je ne présume
pas du tout de la décision des Canadiens
je ne suis pas en train de proclamer la
fin de la monarchie mais je dis que il y
aura certainement des discussions sur la
monarchie constitutionnelle et vous
parliez de la Barbade ce qui est
intéressant c'est que la Barbade a mis
fin à la monarchie constelle il y a
environ un an de cela mais la Barbade
est indépendante depuis moins longtemps
que le Canada d'autres termes il y a
aussi des Canadiens qui considèrent
qu'il est incompatible avec la
souveraineté canadienne que nous
renvoyons comme cela ou que nous
référions aux membres la famille royale
britannique
Estelle j'aimerais qu'on remontre les
images du bandful de Charles parce que
je vous avoue que j'ai été un peu étonné
mais peut-être ne devrais-je pas l'être
de voir Charles descendre de son
véhicule il est le roi il est le roi il
descend et il prend un bain de foule je
me rappelle pas avoir vu la reine
Élisabeth II faire ça est-ce que vous
avez l'impression qu'il veut donner une
nouvelle image ou une autre image à son
règne bien la reine Elizabeth elle en
faisait des des beinfools de cette
nature là mais peut-être pas le
seulement à des événements précis mais
souvenez-vous quand elle est venue au
Canada elle a souvent donné la main à
des gens qui étaient venus
le long des cultures pour trier sur le
volet non non tout comme les
Britanniques que l'on voit maintenant
c'est des gens qui sont là pour
justement rendre hommage dans un premier
temps à la reine mais aussi bon ils ont
la chance le hasard vu que au même le
prince Charles le roi Charles est arrivé
et il a décidé d'aller les saluer et je
pense que ça c'est le fait que il veut
montrer que lui aussi il veut être
proche des gens des Britanniques et de
pouvoir aller rapidement vers eux et on
a vu par les images que les gens étaient
très sympathiques même sur un peu plus
tôt on a même vu une dame qui qui
embrassait le prince Charles il ne s'est
pas repoussé au contraire il a accueilli
ce souhait là avec un sourire des salut
vers les gens qui sont plus salariés
alors combien de temps que ce benful a
duré on le sait pas mais il reste il a
pris aussi le temps de regarder tous les
les bouquets de fleurs qui avaient été
déposées il a pris le temps avec la
reine consort de de passer devant de
faire un aller-retour pour ensuite se
diriger à l'intérieur du palais mais je
pense que ça c'est important autant pour
lui de sentir le poux des gens qui sont
là que pour la foule de lui montrer que
ils sont derrière lui et que mais il
faut pas oublier non plus que il est en
deuil il vient de perdre sa mère et ça
c'est comme un élément qu'on oublie
facilement parce que on voit tout se
décorum ça protocole mais un arrière il
y a l'homme qui qui a la peine de perdre
sa mère et ça c'est ça il va avoir un
deuil national de 10 jours jusqu'au
funérailles mais ensuite le deuil
familial va se poursuivre pour un autre
sept jours et
vraiment c'est lui il va continuer ses
fonctions c'est certain mais ils vont
restreindre un certain nombre
d'activités qu'ils auraient fait
autrement
c'est très dur pour n'importe qui et en
plus il doit vivre ça public avec une
pression sur les épaules pour devenir le
roi des Britanniques en plus donc avec
ce discours notamment qui va prononcer
aujourd'hui juste une précision et celle
qui vous permettez Rennes consort qu'on
sort ça veut dire quoi c'est que ce
n'est pas elle qui a ce n'est pas elle
qui règne c'est son c'est leur roi alors
elle elle porte le titre c'est un but de
dire comme reine de courtoisie alors au
lieu de dire rien de courtoisie on dit
rien ne consort donc c'est par rapport à
la reine qui vient de décéder elle c'est
elle qui régnait alors c'est pas le même
type ne règne pas et il a pas de pouvoir
dans le fond si ce n'est qu'un pouvoir
d'influence peut-être sur le roi oui
mais c'est plus elle est la conjointe
elle est la femme du roi et
parcourtoisie on lui accorde le titre de
reine mais c'est pas ça le pas le même
poids que
le titre de reine qu'ils avaient 2 a
porté elle porte le même titre de reine
que la reine Elizabeth la reine mère
elle était la femme de George VI donc
elle aussi elle était reine Elizabeth
mais elle était reine mais parce qu'elle
était la femme du roi et non pas parce
que c'est elle qui règne et vous la
voyez c'est Camilla au côté de du roi
Charles on a de la difficulté on a
toujours l'envie de dire prince mais
c'est le roi Charles 3 maintenant et en
effet il faut qu'on se rafraîchisse un
peu la mémoire ça fait 70 ans qu'on a
pas vécu une telle situation Benoît je
reviens à la question constitutionnelle
si on veut de la monarchie si on remet
si on fait ce débat au Canada est-ce que
il faut rouvrir la Constitution à ce
moment à la bise qui va y avoir une
volonté pour ouvrir la Constitution
c'est sûr qu'en ce moment les
politiciens disent bien que il y a pas
de d'appétit pour la réforme
professionnelle c'est évident mais vous
savez si la population souhaite vraiment
l'abolition de la monarchie je vois mal
un politicien s'opposer à cela ou
contrecarrer les vœux les lector en
quelque sorte est-ce que la population
le souhaite Benoît est-ce qu'on sait ça
il y a des sondages qui indiquent que le
nombre de Canadiens qui souhaitent
l'abolition de la monarchie et croissant
maintenant est-ce que il se dégagerait
dans un contexte de référendum à titre
d'exemple comme il y en a eu en
Australie il y a quelques années est-ce
qu'ils se dégagerait une majorité
favorable à l'abolition de la monarchie
ça ça reste à voir mais vous savez quand
on me dit
bon il y a pas de politique qui veut
entrer dans la réforme conditionnelle
c'est vrai mais il y a pas non plus un
politicien qui veut se mettre à
contrer le vœu des électeurs et le vœu
du peuple alors si jamais je dis bien si
jamais il y avait une volonté de
d'abolir la monarchie on pourrait même
s'entendre sur une négociation
fonctionnelle de porter limitée qui
n'apporte qui n'apporte que sur cette
question parce que ça n'aurait pas de
retourner à 1000 sur la terre si vous
ouvrez la Constitution faut que vous
l'ouvriez pour tous les les demandes des
autochtones les demandes du Québec
le risque qu'il y a avec ce sujet là
c'est pour ça que tout tous les
politiciens dans évidemment se tiennent
à distance la réforme constitutionnelle
mais vous savez en politique vous le
savez autant que moi et même presque
mieux que moi les choses changent très
vite et donc ce que dit un politicien un
jour est différent de ce qu'on va dire
un an après ou deux ans après alors
l'électorat ça va être à suivre la
levure de l'électorat ça va être à
suivre selon l'évolution de l'opinion
publique en effet avoir donc mais il y a
cette ce moment qui permet peut-être
cette réflexion avec
le fait que le roi Charles devient roi
ou en ce moment je vous invite à rester
là et à continuer d'être disponible pour
nous je vais on va les retrouver ma
collègue Clawdeen Richard qui est à
rideau c'est officielle de la gouverneur
général du pays et Claudine est un livre
de condoléances pour la reine qui a été
ouvert
depuis ce matin et jusqu'à 19h ce soir
peut-être vous notez aussi qu'il y en a
un autre qui est ouvert du côté de
l'hôtel de ville de tawa celui-là ne
sera pas seulement pour une journée mais
c'est depuis ce matin jusqu'à au coucher
du soleil le jour des funérailles
lorsque ce sera décidé mais celui à
rideau World c'est pour aujourd'hui
jusqu'à 19h vous voyez sous ce chapiteau
c'est là que ça se passe à certains
moments de la journée il y avait une
plus longue fil parfois moins et
justement sur les images mais vous le
voyez vous allez voir entre autres
comment la table est arrangée avec un
portrait de la reine donc des gens qui à
tour de rôle sont quand même venus ici
signé le livre des condoléances et autre
chose qu'on peut peut-être vous montrer
en direct de rideau World bien les
drapeaux qui sont en berne bien entendu
ici et qu'ils seront pendant 10 jours
donc les institutions fédérales qui vont
être en quelque sorte en deuil pendant
10 jours et les drapeaux qui vont rester
ici et ce qui se passe à Ottawa pour les
gerbes de fleurs je vous dirais que
c'est un drôle de phénomène là il y a
des gerbes de fleurs à différents
endroits faire va vous expliquer
pourquoi il y en a qui ont été mis bon
ici tout près du livre de condoléances
puis nous ici bien on est dans le jardin
borderidois c'est 79 heures et la
tradition ici c'est différent monarques
rois de différents pays qui viennent et
qui plante parfois des arbres alors il y
en a un entre autres il y en a plus
qu'un par contre là mais il y en a un
entre autres qui étaient planté par la
reine Elisabeth qui se trouve là donc
d'autres fleurs qui ont été posées là
avec un un ruban noir sinon bien il y a
le fait que la fontaine ici est en
rénovation alors il y a d'autres
personnes qui ont cru bon bon de déposer
d'autres gerbes de fleurs devant la
fontaine vous allez voir entre autres la
photo ce à quoi c'est ça ressemble
normalement lorsque la fontaine elle est
en fonction alors il y a des gens qui
ont déposé d'autres Jobs de fleurs ici
il y a une statue aussi qui sont
proposés parce que c'est une bonne
marche un bon 5 minutes de marche ou une
statue qui est dans un rond-point au
centre-ville d'autres gens ont déposé
des là donc on tente à différents
endroits dans la ville de
prêter hommage en fait à la reine et les
messages lorsqu'on les lie en général si
on la remercie pour son règne ses
services on souhaite une longue vie au
nouveau roi parce que on va devoir aussi
s'habituer au fait que ce sera un roi
maintenant plutôt qu'une reine côté il y
aura des changements là aussi mais c'est
un changement d'habitude pour les gens
aussi on n'a pas vu ça depuis 70 ans
quand même faut qu'on s'y habitue
Claudine merci beaucoup
il faut faire erreur la reine est venue
24 fois au pays la dernière fois c'était
en 2015 je pense j'y vais de mémoire
c'est peut-être à cette occasion qu'il
avait planté cet arbre Madeleine bonjour
où êtes-vous Vancouver ou Ottawa je suis
à vancouverte
nous là ça perturbe un peu l'activité
politique ce qui se passe avec la reine
il y a tout un protocole à Ottawa lors
du décès du souverain de la reine ou du
roi expliquez-nous comment ça se passe
mais en ce moment on est dans une
période de deuil qui commence
officiellement Sébastien aujourd'hui ça
va durer 10 jours c'était prévu en fait
il y a tout un protocole effectivement
qui s'enclenche mais qu'on n'avait pas
connu depuis 70 ans donc on dépoussière
des guides de qui avait été préparés et
qui avait quitté en fait toute la
machine était prête une marche à suivre
qui est en train d'être suivi en ce
moment donc drapeau en berne il y a
tranquillement des documents qui vont
être changés je pense par exemple à des
documents qui font référence à la reine
on entendait par exemple aussi que la
Cour du Banc de la Reine va devenir la
cour du bord du roi donc toutes sortes
de nomenclatures comme ça qui va devoirs
qui vont devoir s'adapter à la nouvelle
réalité du nouveau roi donc ça c'est
pour peut-être le côté plus technique
mais quand on pense à toutes les
activités politiques Sébastien ont dit
que le niveau ou le volume d'activité va
être réduit au cours des prochains jours
qu'on va y aller au cas par cas selon ce
qui est essentiel ou non donc lorsque
pas de règle clair et net je vous dirais
que pour les parties ça devient
compliqué parfois de prendre certaines
décisions et je pense aux parties
conservateur qui a demain un congrès
prévu pour choisir son nouveau chef
alors un gros événement qui se voulait
nécessairement festif parce qu'on veut
accueillir le nouveau chef qui devient
du même coup le chef de l'opposition
officielle alors les autorités du parti
se sont rassemblés pour savoir qu'est-ce
qu'on fait avec ça et certains très tôt
le Parti conservateur a décidé d'aller
de l'avant avec le Congrès mais en
reflétant dans le programme la période
de deuil qui est suivie par le
gouvernement fédéral donc j'imagine que
s'il y avait des confettis prévue par
exemple Sébastien en Europe donc pour
essayer de montrer finalement qu'on
respecte aussi ce deuil national et
c'est important parmi certains membres
du Parti conservateur qui sont associés
de prêts à la monarchie qui tienne à la
monarchie je pense par exemple à
l'ancien Premier ministre Steven Harper
qui avait fait retirer les portraits
d'Alfred peller du ministère des
Affaires étrangères pour poser celui ou
poser celui de la reine le portrait de
la reine donc on voit que ça devient une
signature politique parfois que de
s'associer à la reine et ça a été le cas
dans le passé chez le Parti conservateur
si j'ai bien compris il faut que la
chambre adopte une motion de
condoléances et ce qui est question que
on rappelle la chambre plutôt que ce qui
était prévu
c'est possible de le faire mais pour le
mais c'est pas nécessaire de le faire et
pour l'instant Sébastien on n'entend pas
que la chambre va être rappelée plus tôt
que le 19 septembre c'est le retour
prévu de la Chambre des communes cet
automne et entre vous et moi je ça me
surprendrait en fait que les travaux
soient recommence plutôt encore une fois
pour une question d'horaire parce qu'on
peut s'attendre à ce que Justin Trudeau
veuille se rendre au funérailles à
Londres donc là tout ça ça chamboule
aussi l'horaire du Premier ministre donc
de rappeler la chambre rappeler les
députés alors que les libéraux eux ont
un congrès prévu au nouveau produit ça
devient une logistique qui est un peu
compliqué je dis pas que ça se passera
pas mais je vous dirais que pour
l'instant j'ai pas entendu un scénario
ou la chambre serait rappelée plutôt que
prévu parce que si on regarde le
calendrier les funérailles de la reine
doivent avoir lieu dans les 10 jours qui
suivent son décès dix jours ou un peu
plus donc ça se mène au dimanche 18
septembre si je calcule bien ou le lundi
19 la chambre elle revient quand vous
avez dit lundi 19 alors est-ce que ce
sera bel et bien le lundi 19 on verra
bien si la chambre
recommence les travaux comme prévu mais
pour l'instant c'est ce qu'on entend
merci beaucoup Madeleine bon à toi merci
nous sommes un peu plus de 5 minutes de
l'heure prévue pour le premier discours
du roi Charles III c'est un discours
qu'il a enregistré selon ce que nous a
appris Catherine Gauthier un peu plus
tôt et donc sur le coup de 13h notre
heure les Britanniques pourront entendre
pour la première fois leur nouveau roi
le roi Charles III qui prononcera ce
discours alors il y a des attentes
Benoît avez-vous on parle beaucoup du
Commonwealth donc des pays rattacs à la
monarchie britannique dans le Canada
est-ce que vous vous attendez un message
pour les pays du communois oui tout à
fait parce que bon enfin le commonwalt
est sous la direction de Charles depuis
je crois 2018 si je ne m'abuse donc la
reine n'avait préparé en quelque sorte
la succession
à l'avance et une espion qui est
extrêmement importante pour les
relations internationales du Royaume-Uni
d'ailleurs Charles A
peut celui des changements climatiques
on le sait
on a parlé de l'environnement le dossier
autochtone alors ce sont tous des
dossiers qui vont revenir à l'avant-plan
vous savez par rapport à la conversation
que nous avons eu tout à l'heure je
reviens sur le cas de Camila qui est
reine-consard
il est intéressant de savoir que au
moment du mariage de Charles avec Kamila
il avait dit qu'elle ne deviendrait pas
rien de consort ouais ouais absolument
c'est à dire qu'elle n'était pas censée
le devenir
parce que d'abord sa popularité
c'est améliorée auprès des Britanniques
d'une part et d'autre part le au mois de
février 2022 la reine Elizabeth II a
pavé la voie littéralement à ce qu'elle
devienne reine qu'on sort en disant que
elle voyait comme il l'a dans ce rôle
alors évidemment avec si vous me
permettez
la prédiction de la reine c'était
évident que là la voix était une voie
royale pour l'accession finalement à ce
rôle de Rennes de courtoisie comme on
disait précédemment et ça c'est
intéressant Estelle parce que
la route a été sinueuse ces dernières
années pour la reine Elisabeth il y a eu
un moment donné où on avait l'impression
qu'il y avait plus de scandale que de
bonnes nouvelles qui sortait de de
Buckingham palers notamment tout ce qui
est entouré
Diana les Jedi l'entrée de l'autre femme
qui était où l'arrivée plus publique de
l'autre femme qui était Camila comment
la reine a géré tout ça puis le fait que
justement comme Benoît le dire elle a
comme pavé la voix à ce que Kamila
devienne reine consort évidemment
lorsque
au cours de mariage près Charles ce que
ça s'est connu que le camilia
c'était en relation très intime avec le
prince Charles évidemment ça a été des
scandales mais jamais
camion n'a fait de commentaires
là-dessus jamais elle n'a accordé
d'entrevue pour parler de sa situation
et bon malheureusement 97 la princesse
de Galles est décédée dans un accident
et mais ce n'est seulement qu'en 2005
que le prince Charles à l'époque a
épousé camélia donc il y a eu une
période de huit ans qui a permis
doucement au prince Charles de que sa
future épouse commence à faire des
activités
les premières fois que l'eau rencontrée
publiquement il y avait une réception il
est allé invité d'honneur et elle était
une invitée donc ils étaient à la même
réception mais ils étaient pas arrivés
ensemble et par la suite doucement
de vue qui avait d'autres activités que
là il commençaient à arriver ensemble
partir ensemble et doucement aussi les
Britanniques ont commencé il y a eu
beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui étaient à
pro d'accord à ce mariage là mais les
années ont passé et en 2005 bon le
mariage a eu lieu et depuis
Camilla la chose de corps noir à
l'époque et là rempli des tâches
toujours à la famille royale très très
bien et on sentait qu'elle supportait
très bien Charles dans son rôle qu'elle
était aussi auprès de la reine d'une
façon assez constante je suis convaincu
que les deux femmes ont beaucoup échangé
et justement le c'est lors de son
est le fait la reine en fait une
allocution la journée ou à le célébrer
ses 70 ans de règne et c'est là qu'elle
a dit qu'elle souhaitait que
aux côtés du roi Charles
dans moins de 30 secondes dans une
vingtaine de secondes en principe si on
baisse sur le bouton au bon moment le
roi Charles III va prononcer son premier
discours en tant que roi rien Elisabeth
II évidemment est décédé hier il est
devenu roi c'est son premier discours
donc il s'adresse aux britannique je
pense qu'on est prêt à aller écouter
parce que le moment est venu de
l'entendre
une reconnaissance pour son amour
maternel pour
sa main sur pour ces conseils pour
l'exemple
la reine Elizabeth c'était une vie bien
vécue un destin accompli et elle est
pleurer surtout
dans cette réalisation d'une vie entière
de dévouement et je renouvelle ce
dévouement aujourd'hui devant vous à
côté de ce deuil profond que nous
ressentons dans la famille nous
partageons également
dans le commelois et par tout sur le
globe un sentiment de gratitude profonde
pour le plus de 70 ans lors desquels ma
mère à titre de reine a servi les
populations de temps de nations
en 1947 lors de son 21ème anniversaire
elle a promis lors d'une télédiffusion
de Captain
s'adressant comme un ouest
sa vie qu'elle soit courte longue au
service de son peuple
c'était plus qu'une promesse
c'était un engagement profond personnel
qui est défini toute sa vie
elle a consenti des sacrifices au nom de
voir son dévouement
souveraine n'a jamais défailli tout au
long des changements des progrès les
époques de joie et de célébration tout
comme ces moments de tristesse et de
perte
dans cette vie vouée au service nous
avons vu cet amour profond la tradition
de concert avec cette acceptation du
progrès qui nous grandit comme la
science
la fiction l'admiration et le respect
qu'elle a inspiré sont devenus un peu le
symbole de son règne
et comme chaque membre de ma famille
pourrait en témoigner
elle a réuni ses qualités avec de
l'humour de la chaleur et une capacité
vraiment profonde de voir le meilleur en
chacun
je rend hommage aux souvenirs de ma mère
et j’aurais très vite service
je crois savoir que son décès à câble de
tristesse beaucoup d'entre vous et je
partage ce sentiment profond avec vous
tous et toutes quand la reine accédait
au trône la Grande-Bretagne et le monde
vivait encore
les difficultés et les conséquences de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale et vivait
encore selon les conventions de notre
époque depuis 70 ans nous avons vu notre
société se transformer en une société
plurielle les institutions de l'État ont
beaucoup changé également par contre
malgré tous ces défis ces changements
notre nation et la grande famille
dont les traditions et les
accomplissements je suis tellement fier
et bien nous avons fleuri prospéré
nos valeurs sont demeurées doivent
demeurer dans la constance et la
continuité
le rôle est
sans un monarchie demeure tout comme la
relation particulière du souverain
envers l'Église d'Angleterre
l'Église dans laquelle ma foi et si
profondément raciné dans cette fois et
dans les valeurs qu'elle m'inspire j'ai
été élevé à chérir un sentiment de
devoir envers les autres et de respecter
au plus haut point les traditions
précieuses les libertés et les
responsabilités de notre histoire unique
et de notre système de gouvernement
parlementaire
comme la reine l'a fait avec une telle
constance à mon tour maintenant je me
promets d'un être plus profond de
solennité dans les années qui que dieu
me préserve de respecter les traditions
constitutionnelles au cœur de notre
relation et où que vous viviez dans le
Royaume-Uni ou dans les royaumes les
territoires de parsemonde vaste comme il
est et quelle que soit vos horizons
personnelles les professionnels je
m'engage à vous servir avec amour et
respect comme je l'ai fait tout au long
de ma vie
ma vie va bientôt changer bien sûr à la
mesure que je vais assumer mes nouvelles
responsabilités je ne pourrais plus
donner autant de mon temps et de mes
énergies aux oeuvres caritatives et aux
enjeux qui met mon temps préoccupé mais
je sais que ce travail important va
continuer entre les mains sur d'autres
personnes
c'est également un moment de changement
dans ma famille
je compte sur l'amour et le soutien de
ma femme béninique et dans la
reconnaissance de son propre service
depuis notre mariage il y a 17 ans
elle devient reine consort
je sais
qu'elle va semer ses responsabilités
avec un dévouement au devoirs et
vraiment elle est mon roc
William à titre
d'héritier va assumer les titres
écossais contents comptez pour moi il
devient le duc de Cornouaille et assume
les responsabilités pour le duché de
Cornouaille que j'ai assumé pendant plus
de 5 décennies aujourd'hui
je suis fier de
lui conférer le titre de prince de
Galles
pays dont le titre j'ai été le porteur
fier pendant
tant d'années de ma vie
avec Catherine à ses côtés notre
prochain prince et notre princesse vont
continuer à inspirer nos conversations
nationales à aider ramener les marges
vers le centre ou une aide peut te
donner au plus vulnérable j'aimerais
également exprimer mon amour pour Harry
et Meghan à mesure qu'il continue de
bâtir leur vie outre-mer
nous allons nous rassembler comme nation
comme comme l'Ouest et en fait comme
communauté internationale voire mondiale
pour les funérailles de ma mère dans
notre peine et dans notre chagrin
rappelons-nous et inspirons-nous de la
lumière de son exemple
au nom de toute ma famille
je ne puis qu'offrir
les remerciements les plus chers pour
vous condoléances et votre soutien
je ne pourrai jamais exprimer à quel
point cela me touche et à quel point
cela compte pour moi et à ma mère tant
aimée
à mesure que tu commences ton dernier
grand voyage pour
te joindre à mon papa chéri j'aimerais
dire tout simplement ceci merci
maman de ton amour de ton dévouement à
notre famille et à la famille des
nations que tu as servis avec tant de
diligence toutes ces années
puisse les anges
te chanter jusqu'à ton repos ultime vous
venez de voir la première intervention
publique du nouveau roi d'Angleterre le
roi Charles III qui a rendu hommage à sa
mère Elisabeth II décédé hier il a
terminé son intervention en remerciant
papa et maman son père et sa mère pour
tout l'amour et le dévouement qu'ils ont
eu à l'endroit de leur famille de sa
famille et il a fait il a pris
l'engagement de servir
comme sa mère Elisabeth II a servi et de
l'engagement qu'elle avait elle-même
pris en 1947 une promesse de dévouement
à son devoir donc le sens du devoir qui
aspire le roi Charles III sur le trône
d'Angleterre avec les responsabilités
que ça comporte il ajoute je prends un
engagement aussi de défendre et de
respecter la Constitution donc on est
évidemment dans la continuité avec moi
Estelle Boutier et Benoît Pelletier
Estelle Boutier et spécialiste de la
monarchie Benoît Pelletier professeur de
droit constitutionnel Benoît dans ce que
vous avez entendu qu'est-ce qui retient
à votre attention d'abord non seulement
son engagement a servi le peuple à
servir ce sujet mais aller servir toute
sa vie c'est faux ça c'est très très
important c'est à dire que il prend un
peu comme vous l'avez dit le même
engagement que sa mère mais pour sa vie
durant pour le pour le reste de sa vie
donc ceux qui spéculer sur des volontés
ou des vérités d'abdication éventuelles
ou de passation du trône prématuré
il est fatal en quelque sorte
deuxièmement il rappelle comme il se
devait le principe d'une monarchie
constitutionnelle c'est à dire qu'on
n'est pas dans une monarchie absolue on
est dans une monarchie où le souverain
doit respecter la Constitution et où par
ailleurs j'ajouterai les pouvoirs du
souverains sont limités par les
conventions constitutionnelles il a
également fait une allusion au
changement de l'état et sans le dire
vraiment on vivre ensemble à l'autre
terme le fait que l'État maintenant est
de plus en plus
composé de gens d'origine
diverses et que dans le fond l'État
s'est transformé mais en même temps du
style la mon qui reste et c'est
peut-être ça le plus grand
héritage Elizabeth II c'est que la
monarchie est encore vivante aujourd'hui
et le monde entier a les yeux tournés
vers cette famille royale en d'autres
mots quand on s'interroge sur le lac
d'Elizabeth évidemment on peut pas
regarder des décisions politiques elle
n'a pas à en prendre elle n'avait pas en
prendre mais son lynx c'est d'avoir
préserver la monarchie jusqu'à ce jour
et ça Charles veut continuer et va
éventuellement dans la même lancée et la
première ministre lise trust qui
s'adressait à la Chambre des communes ce
matin disait elle était le rock
en Angleterre donc même si ça allait pas
bien parce que ça va pas bien en
Angleterre par les dents qui courent les
gens sont pas contents l'inflation
notamment il y a des problèmes des
tensions sociales mais elle restait le
rock inébranlable et donc les les
Britanniques pouvaient se projeter sur
elle pour garder le cap Estelle
qu'est-ce que vous retenez donc de ce
premier discours cette première
intervention du roi Charles bien
évidemment le long hommage qui l'a rendu
à sa mère on sentait beaucoup d'émotions
et
évidemment il a enchaîné aussi avec le
fait que il voulait
sa foi
était
importante pour lui mais pas seulement
la sienne mais toutes les types de fois
qui peut avoir elles sont importantes et
il veut que tout le monde soit reconnu
dans ça oui exactement et comme vous
l'avez dit aussi le fait de continuer à
servir le pays
jusqu'à sa fin à lui aussi
ça c'est certain pendant longtemps on
entendait des commentaires que bon on
s'entraîne génération que le prince
Charles le roi Charles
il passerait le trône à son fils mais là
il a bien précisé que non lui il était
aussi pour travailler à servir son son
pays
les membres du commonwealt et d'essayer
de trouver des solutions ensemble c'est
important pour lui et il a reconnu que
la présence de de Camilla à ses côtés
était extrêmement importantes il a
encore de nouveau confirmé qu'elle
porterait le titre de reine-consard et
il n'a pas attendu
plus d'une journée pour confirmer que
désormais le prince William
porterait le titre de prince de Galles
parce que Charles était prince de Galles
n'est-ce pas oui Charles était prince de
Galles mais lorsque
elisabeth est devenu reine en 52
Charles avait seulement trois ans alors
que elle lui a accordé le titre de
prince de Galles seulement en 1958 et il
a été
investi du titre seulement en 1969 alors
qu'il était un jeune homme et
alors que là on voit immédiatement il le
fait immédiatement que lui-même avait eu
peut-être pas bon il est enfant à
l'époque mais aussi on remonte encore
plus dans le temps à l'époque où quand
le roi Édouard 7 a accéder au trône il a
attendu un an et demi avant de décerner
le titre de prince de Galles à son
héritier donc on voit que chacun y va
selon
ce qu'il entend mais ça ça a été
pour être franc je ne pensais pas qu'il
le nommerait dès maintenant mais il l'a
fait et
parlant de nommer où il a nommé Harry et
Meghan oui c'était ce que j'allais dire
et les hommes nommés
reste son fils Miguel reste sa
belle-fille même si mais il a dit que
bon toutes les deux ils avaient choisi
d'aller vivre aux États-Unis mais il les
a quand même nommés dans son discours
alors on sent très bien que du comment
vous interprétez ça bien c'est ça a été
c'est certain que on sait que les
relations sont tendues mais quand même
il a voulu marquer le fait que
il y a deux fils il y a William il y a
Harry et c'était important j'en suis
certaine pour lui de nommer aussi
son fils et sa famille dans son discours
[Musique]
il est toujours prince il est ils sont
toujours Jack de sa sexe la seule
chose c'est que
il n'utilise plus
l'appellation Son Altesse Son Altesse
Royale donc ça ils l'ont toujours mais
il ne l'utilise plus pour guider nos
téléspectateurs au bas de l'écran vous
voyez une messe commémorative à la
cathédrale Saint-Paul alors que dans
l'écran plus haut c'est le château de
Windsor ou des gens se sont accueillis
ou des gens ont apporté notamment des
fleurs pour rendre hommage à la reine
Elizabeth II décédé hier Benoît je
m'attendais un bout un peu plus
peut-être de messages sur le commonworth
est-ce que vous avez noté quelque chose
dans le discours de Monsieur de Monsieur
du roi Charles III de messages envers
les pays du commonment non pas vraiment
son discours était particulièrement bref
je dois dire pour une dizaine de minutes
je pensais que ça serait plus long bon
je peux comprendre que la Borde pas des
sujets épineux
maintenant et peut-être qu'il ne le fera
plus d'ailleurs maintenant que les rois
je pense encore au changement climatique
et ainsi de suite mais à tout événement
je me serais tendu à ce que il en dise
plus sur comment
words en quelque sorte encore une fois
étant donné la position très stratégique
qu'occupe cette association d'État dans
les affaires étrangères du Royaume-Uni
alors
j'ai été quand même surpris de voir que
ils ont dit c'est pas plus sur le sujet
est-elle on n'a pas une deuxième chance
de faire une première bonne impression
et il y a beaucoup de gens qui se
questionnent sur l'étoffe de roi de
Charles III est-ce qu'il a l'étoffe pour
occuper ce poste là est-ce qu'il a les
qualités nécessaires comment vous avez
trouvé
ce qu'on peut appeler ça une prestation
en tout cas le ton les mots la forme du
discours je crois que oui l'étoffe
c'est aussi je crois que
il a voulu faire passer le message que
son premier discours il s'était vraiment
l'hommage à sa mère et
d'assurer tout le monde que il voulait
faire suivre son exemple et dédié aussi
sa vie
à poursuivre ce que sa mère a fait
pendant toute sa vie alors le discours
c'est sûr moi aussi je m'attendais à ce
qui parle un peu plus du commonweb de
ces engagements pour
l'environnement les autochtones mais en
même temps d'une façon très
un survol seulement seulement dire que
c'est des projets que bon on aura
travaillé ensemble il n'a même pas fait
ça il a commencé son discours en rando
hommage à la reine et il a terminé son
discours en rendant de nouveau à sa mère
et à son père c'était peut-être plus
c'était autant peut-être sinon plus le
feu le fils endeuillé aujourd'hui qui
parlait que le roi qui a des messages
politiques avec toute la réserve que
cela nécessite à envoyer vous restez là
s'il vous plaît on va les retrouver Eric
Albert qui est notre qui est
correspondant pour le monde à Londres
Eric merci de prendre quelques minutes
pour nous avec le décalage horaire
qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé donc du
discours de Charles III
c'était un discours qui était quand même
intéressant parce que moi je retiens
trois grands messages qui ont déjà été
soulignés mais il y avait bien sûr un
hommage appuyé à la reine c'était
nécessaire c'était une personnalité de
toute manière en du commun et c'est
vraiment ce que les Britanniques que
j'ai vu devant Buckingham Palace qui
vient de porter des fleurs ou hypark 10
tous étaient ils sont pas surpris que
cette dame de 96 ans soit décédée mais
ils sont tous très tristes et ils sont
tous tous ils disent la même chose merci
le merci la gratitude c'est le message
qui revient tout le temps donc c'est ce
que j'entends chez le roi Charles III le
deuxième chose c'était bien sûr je
renouvelle le serment que ma mère a fait
a fait quand elle avait 21 ans je vais
servir vous tous bien sûr les choses ont
changé les institutions ont changé on
est dans un monde plus multiculturel
mais nos valeurs n'ont pas changé c'est
la phrase qu'il a utilisé nos valeurs
restent les mêmes ma vie va changer mais
nos valeurs restent les mêmes donc la
monarchie aujourd'hui encore en creux il
répond à monarchie est encore importante
c'est ce qui dit en creux et puis le
troisième message c'est aussi il se met
vraiment dans sa famille c'est
intéressant qu'il parle de sa femme
Camilla de son fils William il sait que
il sera par définition un roi plus de
transition même ça dure une vingtaine
d'années ça ne sera jamais comparable à
la reine donc moi c'est comme ça que je
le vois en tout cas ce message de
William est déjà est présent également
et aussi effectivement probablement une
branche d'olivier vis-à-vis de son fils
Harry
on le demande directement c'est moi
c'est vraiment les messages que que j'en
retire et juste une chose il a quand
même parlé du Commonwealth à plusieurs
reprises le commémorat était très
important pour pour sa mère en tout le
monde le sait il l'a pas oublié il n'a
peut-être pas insisté suffisamment mais
il l'a vraiment pas oublié
dites-moi quelle relation les
Britanniques ont avec Charles parce que
il y a eu la tragédie de Lady die il y a
eu l'autre femme qui est entrée en scène
qui a reçu la bénédiction si on comprend
de la reine au cours des dernières
années
la reine était ce rock qui maintenait la
monarchie ensemble malgré tous les
scandales puis de chez nous on a
l'impression que c'était plus une
affaire de potins d'infidélité de
scandale que une affaire de monarchie et
de roi et de Rennes quelle est la
relation donc entre les Britanniques et
le roi Charles III
il y a des sondages qui sont implacables
la reine avait une cote de popularité de
75%, William de 66% Charles 42% il est
beaucoup moins populaire c'est un fait
et ça fait des décennies c'est comme ça
mais tous les gens à qui j'ai parlé
devant moi qu'un Palès ou à éparpouiller
avec cette célébration un coup de canon
lui donne le bénéfice du doute il y a
une dame qui me disait quelque chose de
très intéressant qui me disait vous
savez personne ne sera jamais aussi
populaire que la reine donc oui il est
moins populaire que la reine c'est
évident mais elle était imbattable en
quelque sorte et donc on lui laisse le
bénéfice du doute mais souvent les gens
quand ils me parlaient me disaient
j'espère que j'espère que
il ne donnera pas trop son opinion
j'espère que il a pris le temps
d'apprendre dans l'ensemble et 25 ans
que Diana est morte ça fait très
longtemps que
l'aigreur de cette époque était vraiment
très forte c'est dissiper maintenant
quand Camilla était nommé par la reine
consort personne n'a réagi quand même au
moment du mariage était en 2005 il y a
eu pratiquement aucune manifestation de
royaliste qui était contre cette mariage
donc de l'eau à passer sous les ponts il
est peu populaire mais je pense que les
Britanniques dans l'ensemble sont prêts
à lui donner du bénéfice du doute alors
on va terminer là-dessus donc c'était un
peu un test peut-être d'une certaine
façon c'est allocution d'une dizaine de
minutes avez-vous l'impression que les
gens qui disent j'espère que on trouvait
que
leur espoir était était rassasié
c'est-à-dire que le roi a fait bonne
première impression
il va falloir leur demander de vendre
mais mais mais je pense que ce discours
a relativement
touché au but à savoir un hommage très
très appuyé à la race des inévitable
mais c'était relativement bien dit
c'était aussi personnels
aussi ils sont dans l'état d'esprit de
rendre hommage
en hommage dire merci c'est intéressant
c'est vraiment un mot qui revient très
très souvent merci pour votre service
vous nous avez fait une promesse quand
vous aviez 21 ans vous nous avez jamais
trahi vous n'avez jamais mis un pas fait
un faux pas j'ai quelqu'un qui me disait
ça et c'est assez vrai on peut retourner
et les républicains diraient elle n'a
jamais rien dit d'intéressant en 70 ans
mais en quelque sorte c'est sa fonction
de ne rien dire d'intéressant c'est ce
qu'elle a réussi à faire et
Charles je pense relativement touché au
but mais les quelques jours qui se
jouent il va faire une tournée des
quatre nations du Royaume-Uni pendant
les journées qui viennent sont
extraordinairement importantes pour son
futur règne si il se trompe s'il fait un
mauvais pas dans les jours qui viennent
ils le payera tout son règne donc je
pense que tout a été mesuré qui sait
exactement ce qui doit faire mais c'est
extrêmement précieux extrêmement
dangereux comme comme période pour lui
intéressant donc ce sera peut-être
l'occasion de se reparler Eric Albert
correspondant pour le monde à Londres
merci de nous avoir parlé et bonne
soirée à vous merci très bonne journée
au revoir nous allons faire un petit
détour par la cathédrale Saint-Paul ou
une messe commémorative et célébrée
allons écouter un peu comment ça se
passe
[Musique]
si nous vivons nous
vivons pour le Seigneur et si nous
mourrons nous mourrons pour le Seigneur
alors que nous vivions que nous mourions
nous appartenons Seigneur
Jésus est mort et a ressuscité pour
qu'il puisse être le seigneur des
vivants comme des morts
pourquoi juger vous votre frère ou votre
sœur
ou vous pourquoi vous détestez votre
frère votre sœur car nous serons tous
devant le jugement de Dieu car il est
écrit comme j'ai vécu des Seigneur
chaque genou fléchira devant moi et
chaque langue
louangera le Seigneur alors c'est ainsi
que chacun et chacune d'entre nous
devront répondre devant Dieu
[Musique]
on est donc devoir en direct une messe à
la cathédrale Saint-Paul de Londres en
hommage à la reine Elizabeth II décédée
hier vous avez entendu la première
ministre lise Strauss lire des passages
de la Bible madame cross a fait ce que
aucun autre Premier ministre n'a fait
dans les 70 dernières années
c'est-à-dire de se présenter à la reine
il y a 72 heures je pense qu'il y a
trois jours elle était allée à Balmoral
au château de Balmoral en Écosse se
présentait à la reine parce qu'elle est
devenue première ministre il y a
quelques jours à peine en succédant à
Boris Johnson et aujourd'hui elle est
première ministre sous un nouveau roi
qui est le roi Charles III la reine
Elizabeth avait 15 premiers ministres en
fait avaient été succédé pendant le
règne de la première de la reine pendant
le règne de la reine Elizabeth II et
Madame Strauss donc a été la dernière et
la première du règne de Charles III
voilà donc pour cette petite parenthèse
se trouve Estelle Bouthier et Benoît
Pelletier pour parler de du discours de
l'intervention publique qui a fait
Charles c'est intéressant le changement
qu'il va devoir opérer Benoît parce que
il avait l'habitude de prendre position
sur des enjeux vous en avez parlé les
l'environnement les autochtones
notamment là est-ce que son sa couronne
qui n'a pas encore sur la terre mais sa
couronne qui leur a bientôt sur la tête
de roi l'empêche dorénavant de prendre
ce genre de position de faire ce genre
d'intervention sur la place publique
Benoît non je ne crois pas évidemment
bon il doit être très prudent
normalement le monarque ne se mêle pas
de question politique on le sait mais en
même temps ce qu'il va falloir voir
jusqu'où il va vouloir transformer la
monarchie
je veux dire là on tient pour acquis que
il va
continuer sur la même lancée que
Elisabeth II mais il est possible qu'il
veuille apporter un certain de réforme
il est vu dans certains milieux comme
l'homme du siècle dernier et là il va
falloir il va vouloir refaire son image
et il est bien parti parce qu'on voit
que bon enfin il se rapproche du peuple
aujourd'hui on a vu on l'a vu en train
de serrer des mains
à Londres il se rapproche du peuple et
en même temps ma faut dire que il n'a
pas de décision politique à prendre donc
s'il veut ne pas être trop controversé
il y a moyen de le faire et en même
temps là je suis très terre à terre mais
ils ont un bon une bonne équipe de
marketing et le marketing monarchique ne
doit pas être négligé dans ce sens où
c'est aussi une question d'image
publique et puis et puis donc je pense
que il va petit à petit gagner davantage
de popularité auprès de la population
Estelle la reine Elizabeth était très
discrète je pense que c'est ma collègue
de symboles gorghisk qui disait ça hier
elle n'a jamais donné une entrevue pour
se préserver donc si le roi Charles est
dans cette continuité il sera très
discret aussi mais sa personnalité
est-elle une personnalité discrète
Estelle c'est certain que par le passé
le roi Charles a mis des opinions assez
arrêtés sur un certain nombre de sujets
maintenant le fait qu'il soit lui-même
la reconnaissait que en tant que Prince
Héritier il pouvait se permettre un peu
de
d'en dire plus que la monarque mais il
reste que maintenant que c'est lui qui
est à la tête du royaume il va
certainement faire extrêmement attention
à ce qu'il va dire mais je crois en même
temps que il va peut-être essayer de
pousser un peu les limites de ce qu'il a
droit de dire évidemment ça se fera pas
la semaine prochaine ou mais doucement
sur certains thèmes qui lui sont chers
j'ai l'impression que il va peut-être
essayer d'en dire un petit peu plus mais
évidemment
ça part de par sa position le fait que
ce soit au-dessus
de la politique et bien son rôle c'est
de
c'est d'aider le Premier ministre qui
lui elle a les pouvoirs de changer des
choses lui il peut conseiller prévenir
dire attention il faut aussi regarder
cette option là face à ce problème donc
ça va être là
qui va pouvoir
émettre son opinion ça va être à son
premier ministre et c'est cette personne
là qui va décider si elle accepte ou pas
les conseils du roi mais il pourra pas
dire mais je suis pas d'accord avec le
Premier ministre donc il va peut-être il
va peut-être vouloir donner sa
personnalité à son règne de monarque
Benoît nous avons appris je vous deviez
le savoir mais moi j'ai appris ça dans
la série the crown que toutes les
semaines la reine Elizabeth rencontrer
le Premier ministre c'est une tradition
importante selon vous qui doit être
maintenu par le roi Charles ah ben oui
tout à fait je crois que cette rencontre
là a lieu le mardi soir
et on m'a dit que c'était à 18h par
ailleurs mais oui oui c'est une c'est
une tradition et en même temps ça
démontre qu'au Royaume-Uni la reine ou
le roi sont vraiment dans une zone
d'influence politique et je me souviens
d'avoir déjà dit ça moi du Gouverneur
général du Canada il y a quelques années
j'avais été très critiqué on m'avait dit
que j'exagérais c'est vrai que dans le
cas du Gouverneur général bon zone
d'influence politique c'est très relatif
mais dans le cas de la reine ou du roi
là c'est réel et sont dans une zone
d'influence politique ils font des
recommandations il s'oppose même sur
certains sujets carrément au Premier
ministre il y a eu des conflits de
personnalité qui résultaient finalement
de du fait qu'il ne partageait pas le
même point de vue sur certaines
questions sensibles alors donc
Cristiano relation entre la monarchie et
le régime britannique qui est différent
de celle qui existe entre la monarchie
et le régime canadien très intéressant
bien imaginez le bagage d'informations
qu'il a accumulé la reine Elizabeth au
fil des 70 ans et au fil de non
seulement ces rencontres avec le Premier
ministre britannique mais avec tous les
autres chefs d'État ou de gouvernement
qu'il a pu rencontrer pendant sa vie
Madeleine blémorin qui nous écoutent de
Vancouver vous avez quelque chose à
ajouter là-dessus maintenant je voulais
intervenir sur le sujet à savoir est-ce
que le roi va pouvoir se comporter comme
il se comportait lorsqu'il était prince
héritier et il avait accordé une
entrevue à la BBC lorsqu’il a eu 70 ans
en disant je suis pas si stupide que ça
je sais très bien que je vais devoir
adapter mon comportement que je ne
pourrais plus prendre le même genre de
position que je prenais lorsque j'étais
prince héritier et que je n'étais pas le
roi du Royaume-Uni le roi d'autres États
par le fait même donc on sent très bien
qu'il était conscient qu'il allait de
voir adapter sa façon d'agir garder une
plus grande réserve face à certains
dossiers par exemple j'imagine au
changement climatiques un dossier qui
lui tenait beaucoup à coeur oui puis on
verra donc quel personnalité il donne à
son règne pendant que je vous ai avec
nous un Madeleine parlez-moi de Justin
Trudeau parce que si vous êtes à
vancouverte c'est parce qu'il y avait
une retraite du cabinet donc du Conseil
des ministres de Monsieur Trudeau est-ce
que ça a été bousculé donc par le décès
de la reine hier ah oui tout à fait hier
matin on devait avoir un point de presse
Sébastien pour annoncer des grandes
politiques du gouvernement en
collaboration avec le NPD pour faire
face à l'inflation ça devait être le
point culminant de cette rencontre du
cabinet en préparation aux travaux
parlementaires qui reprennent dans un
peu plus d'une semaine à Ottawa il
devait être question par exemple de
soins dentaires de crédit d'impôts pour
la TPS question aussi d'aide au logement
et on attendait un point de presse tout
d'un coup tout ça a été chamboulé et je
vous dirais que l'ambiance a changé
aussi au sein du cabinet on avait vu par
exemple Christophe Freeland passer avec
sa petite robe rouge libérale et la voir
aller changer pour remporter une noire
alors tout d'un coup on a compris
qu'avec quelque chose qui se passait
Sébastien pouvait pas absolument
conclure au décès de la reine mais on
commençait en couler ça s'en douter un
peu parce que je vous dirais que les
visages étaient lourds donc tout ça
c'est passé hier on a vu aussi juste un
Trudeau prendre la parole mais ne pas
prendre de questions pour rendre hommage
à la reine et on le sentit bouleversé on
le sentit émus parce qu'il connaissait
la reine depuis qu'il était tout petit
il était le 12e Premier ministre à avoir
servi sous la reine donc son père Pierre
Eliot Trudeau avait aussi servi sous la
reine la connaissait donc depuis qu'il
était tout petit il a parlé de son sens
de l'humour de son des conseils aussi
qu'il recevaient d'elle et ça c'était un
premier témoignage qu'on a entendu ça a
été suivi de plusieurs autres notamment
des anciens premiers ministres je pense
par exemple la Brian Muller qui parlait
aussi de sa dignité en quelque sorte
face à son rôle de Jean-Chrétien
Jean-Chrétien qui a répondu à des
questions sur le rôle de la monarchie au
Canada en disant ça fait partie de nos
institutions et le système en ce moment
fonctionne ça me faisait penser à une
expression en anglais donc fixe et
effectivement broken n'essayez pas de
réparer quelque chose qui n'est pas
cassé donc ça c'était les commentaires
de gens chrétiens à propos de la
monarchie constitutionnelle au Canada
mais j'entendais monsieur Pelletier tout
à l'heure dire que peut-être qu'il y a
un débat qui va refaire surface au
Canada avec le passage avec cette
succession à laquelle on assiste
peut-être bien parce que la monarchie
constitutionnelle si elle était appuyée
à peu près un Canadien sur deux au
Canada dans les sondages on montre bien
que lorsque la reine allait
nécessairement décédée le taux
d'approbation à la monarchie
constitutionnelle prenait quand même
diminuer quand même de façon assez
substantielle vous avez vous avez parlé
de gens chrétiens jeunes chrétiens
disaient aussi qu'il parlaient français
avec la reine qui parlait un excellent
français de même que son prince Philippe
son conjoint Madeleine merci beaucoup
nous allons passer devant couverts à
Winnipeg on trouvait Jérémy Bergeron
parce que Jérémy l'arrivée d'un nouveau
roi a déjà un impact au Manitoba
expliquez-nous lequel
en fait on se trouve devant le palais de
justice de Winnipeg de Sébastien et se
trouve à l'intérieur la Cour du Banc du
Roi jusqu'à hier c'était la Cour du Banc
de la Reine il y a encore quatre
provinces au pays qui qui a le nom du
roi ou de la reine pour nommer la Cour
supérieure au Québec c'est le cas du
Manitoba de l'Alberta de la saskachuan
et du Nouveau-Brunswick et rapidement
systématiquement la mort de la reine
Elizabeth c'est devenu la cour du bas du
roi je veux vous montrer un petit
document ici là on est allé chercher un
papier et l'on n'a pas perdu tant déjà
aujourd'hui l'entête du document en
cours criminel est écrit de 15 bench
donc la cour du bas du roi un peu plus
bas par contre il y a une étampe pour
dire que le document a bien été reçu
c'est toujours la Cour du Banc de la
Reine
on n'a pas changé les temps encore mais
j'imagine que ça ce n'est qu'une
question de temps avant qu'on va
commander tout ça faudra s'habituer sur
les sites internet aussi un peu partout
dans les provinces des Prairies du
Nouveau-Brunswick on la marque déjà le
nom a changé c'est plutôt administratif
symbolique par ceux d'un côté procédural
il y a rien qui change toutes les causes
étaient entendues aujourd'hui comme à
l'habitude c'est vraiment plutôt les
entaides de documents et tout ça qui
change avec l'arrivée du nouveau roi par
contre on a parlé à plusieurs à votre
place ce matin et un peu comme Madeleine
est-ce qu'il y aura un nouveau débat
entourant la monarchie parce qu'il y a
des gens qui se demandent si on devrait
pas changer le nom de cette Cour
supérieure pour avoir un nom un peu plus
neutre surtout avec les parties
coloniales ça a un lourd passé pour pour
les gens donc on se demande si je ne
serai peut-être pas le temps d'avoir une
réflexion sur l'idée de renommer ces
cours-là cours supérieurs comme ça se
voit un peu partout au pays mais ça
pourrait prendre du temps parce que vous
changez des lois tout ça c'est pas de
même matin la veille qu'on va changer le
nom du de la Cour du Banc du Roi va
falloir s'habituer ici aussi merci
Jérémy donc on s'aperçoit qu'il y a des
changements qui doivent être faits puis
juste un mot sur les pièces de monnaie
parce que sur les par exemple il y a le
profil de la reine profil droit de la
reine semble-t-il bah oui vous le voyez
là sur les pièces de 5 sous et
dorénavant mais ça c'est une pièce en
Australie c'est un média un journal
australien qui a publié le profil gauche
donc du roi Charles parce qu'il y a une
alternance selon le roi ou la reine
c'est pas une alternance homme femme
c'est plutôt une alternance qui est sur
le trône donc c'était le profil droit de
la reine et dorénavant ça devrait être
le profil gauche du roi sur les pièces
de monnaie une fois qu'elles seront
refrappées ou refaites nous allons
retrouver Maryline Bastien qui est une
Québécoise qui vit à Londres depuis 15
ans madame Bastien merci de prendre
quelques minutes avec nous dites-moi
comment vous avez réagi lorsque vous
avez appris hier que la reine Elizabeth
II était morte
que je pense que comme plusieurs autres
personnes on pensait qu'elle allait être
là pour toujours après 70 ans de règne
on est tellement habitué puis pour
plusieurs on a juste connu une reine
donc cette nouvelle est arrivée comme un
chat puis c'est aussi une très grande
tristesse quand on quand on comprend
combien tout juste de célébrer son
Platinum
a montré au monde entier que ça fait 70
ans qui est en place puis quand elle a
toujours
une importance une implication au niveau
de représenter le Royaume-Uni que
cette nouvelle suit quelques semaines
après c'est c'est extrêmement triste moi
je trouve mais les gens que vous
connaissez à Londres ou à qui vous
parlez quelle relation les Britanniques
ont avec la reine vous vous venez
évidemment du Canada on est monarchie
constitutionnelle ici mais quelle
relation les Britanniques que vous
connaissez ont avec la monarchie en
Angleterre en Grande-Bretagne
et la monarchie comme tel je pense qu'il
y a la monarchie c'est sa famille
étendue je pense que malheureusement
dernièrement il y a eu quelques
nouvelles qui étaient plus ou moins
glorieuse pour la famille
royale mais je pense que la reine comme
tel elle avait vraiment un pouvoir de
rassemblement puis je pense que elle a
vraiment démontré surtout ces dernières
années en passant au travers
la covid-19 avec tous les confinements
le fait que vraiment raisonné au niveau
de des gens qui ont été beaucoup de
monde à continuer à respecter les règles
de confinement etc tant que à l'opposé
on avait les partis politiques qui
essayaient aussi de d'impliquer des
règlements etc qui eux bon finalement on
apprend qui ont même pas respecter ce
qui est impliqué donc
c'est sûr qu'il
est pas mêlée à la politique je pense
que ça lui permet de pas polariser la
nation puis d'avoir plus un espèce de
rôle de rassembleur je pense que c'est
dans mon environnement dans les gens que
je connais dans dans ma belle-famenne
c'est vraiment de cette façon qui voit à
la fin que c'est une personne qui
rassemble et comment voit-il Charles
parce que il y a des gens qui se posent
des questions sur l'étoffe qu'il a pour
devenir roi enfin il devient roi on va
voir si là s'il est dans la continuité
il a je sais pas si vous avez eu
l'occasion d'écouter son discours son
allocution il y a 45 minutes environ où
il veut s'inscrire dans la continuité
donc comment Charles est-il perçu
effectivement essayé d'écouter le plus
possible à travers les cris de mes
petites filles mais
je pense qu'il y a une très grande
job à
accomplir une grande personne à suivre
donc ça sera pas facile je pense que ça
va être un défi de trouver sa place avec
sa façon de voir les choses sans
offenser des des ferveurs de la reine
des gens qui étaient vraiment fans de la
reine puis je pense que il y a une bonne
partie de la nation qui aurait peut-être
aimé savoir une personne devenir en
place qui serait peut-être un peu plus
jeune
donc c'est un petit utile de savoir je
pense qu'il faut laisser la chance au
courant mais je pense que c'est sûr que
il y a beaucoup de monde aussi qui
aimerait peut-être voir sans nouveau
dans en place au niveau de stop la
royauté
le roi Charles a dit je vais être là le
temps que je serai là c'est à dire le
temps que je suis vivant donc c'est
peut-être fait taire les espoirs de
certaines personnes qui espérait
peut-être que il passerait le flambeau à
son fils William juste une petite
question personnelle qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qui vous amène à Londres
pourquoi êtes-vous basé en Angleterre
depuis une quinzaine d'années
[Musique]
puis je suis resté accroché à
présentement je travaille pour une
compagnie de design qui s'appelle House
mais puis
le postmètre le créateur de la marque
qui est maintenant
et est encore à la barre de l'entreprise
avec lui qu'on fait toutes nos meeting
puis c'est un designer britannique très
réputé pour du vêtement pour homme
coloré qui est aussi je pense eu une
très bonne relation avec la reine la
royauté ayant été lui-même nommé sœur et
je peux exactement le titre mais je sais
qu'il y a reçu quelques titres de la
alors merci beaucoup madame Bastien
d'avoir pris le temps nous parler je
sais qu'il est plus tard chez vous merci
c'est très apprécié on n'a pas entendu
des décrits d'enfants donc ça c'est bien
passé merci beaucoup et bonne soirée
ma collègue Michel Brideau parce que
plusieurs réactions chez vous Michel
oui il y a plusieurs réactions on a
beaucoup senti dans la communauté
acadienne de la tristesse un choc aussi
de voir que la reine Elisabeth II soit
décédée parce qu'il y avait quand même
un attachement envers la reine et c'est
assez particulier c'est parce que on
c'est une relation entre Acadia et
couronne britannique particulière en
raison de la déportation des Acadiens en
1755 autant on est triste autant qu'il
reste toujours chez les Acadiens ce
sentiment d'avoir été déportés et de
vivre encore aujourd'hui cette
déportation les conséquences de la
déportation c'est la raison pour
laquelle le 15 août cette fête nationale
acadienne on l'a fait souvent à grands
coups de tintamarre pour dire on est
debout toujours on parle toujours le
français sauf qu'il y a des gens qui ont
encore aujourd'hui
aimeraient que la Couronne britannique
s'excuse pour cette déportation des
Acadiens en 1755 et d'ailleurs il y
avait 20 ans il y a des Acadiens qui ont
tenté d'obtenir des excuses de la
Couronne britannique de la reine
Élisabeth II finalement ce qu'ils
avaient obtenu c'est non pas des excuses
mais plutôt une reconnaissance des torts
causés aux Acadiens avec cette
déportation les Acadiens aussi le 28
juillet est devenu la journée
commémorative du Grand Dérangement au
Canada alors à l'époque aussi il y avait
20 ans le lieutenant gouverneur du
Nouveau-Brunswick c'était un Acadia et
lui il était contre les excuses une
demande d'excuse il pense que
reconnaître les torts c'était bien
suffisant on l'a rencontré ce matin
je pense que justement les excuses ça
entraîne une réparation une compensation
tandis que
avec la proclamation s'en est sorti
d'une manière assez élégante
évidemment je pense que ça ça aide
alors est-ce qu'il pourrait y avoir
maintenant des excuses alors qu'on a le
roi Charles III et bien ce qu'il faut
comprendre avec tout ça c'est que c'est
pas c'est d'abord le gouvernement du
Canada qui doit recommander à la
Couronne britannique des excuses il y a
20 ans le gouvernement Canadien n'avait
pas voulu recommander des excuses alors
il faudrait que le gouvernement actuel
d'abord recommande à la Couronne
britannique au roi Charles qu'il fasse
des excuses au peuple acadien mais en
même temps monsieur Chiasson a parlé
tout à l'heure ça vient avec un
dédommagement probablement si on fait
des excuses est-ce que ça veut dire que
ça coûterait cher beaucoup d'argent
alors c'est peut-être cet aspect qui
fait que il y a pas eu d'excuses il y a
20 ans on sait pas s'il y en aura un
jour mais bon alors cette relation entre
les Acadiens et la Couronne britannique
et demeurer particulière en raison de la
déportation mais je dois vous dire quand
même que les réactions sont nombreuses
et bien les Acadiens reconnaissent tout
l'apport de la reine Elizabeth II le la
stabilité
rassurer pendant ces 70 ans cette porte
que ça pourrait ouvrir en effet sur
cette discussion Michel merci beaucoup
bonne après-midi à vous nous allons
faire un saut à la cathédrale Saint-Paul
de Londres ou une messe commémorative en
hommage à la reine Elizabeth II et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cathédrale Saint-Paul de Londres donc
Metz hommage mais c'est quand même
entier va hommage à la reine Elizabeth
II décédé hier je retrouve pour conclure
Estelle Boutier et Benoît Pelletier
Benoît je trouve intéressant de quand
même la porte que Michel ouvrait dans la
converses qu'on vient tout juste de
faire à Mountain sur l'idée que
certaines personnes pensent que c'est
peut-être le moment d'avoir réparation
pour
ce qui est arrivé aux Acadiens mais
aussi l'esclavagisme à travers le monde
et la responsabilité de la Couronne
britannique est-ce que vous pensez que
ce débat là va se faire avec la
situation au trône de Charles III ben
écoutez je l'espère parce que je ne
pense pas que des excuses en train de
nécessairement une réparation là on
parle d'une réparation monétaire la
plupart du temps je ne pense pas que des
excuses en train de cela je pense que ce
serait tout à fait bienvenue par rapport
aux Acadiens je comprends terminé Gilles
de Chiasson parce que il a été
lieutenant gouverneur d'être prudent sur
la question mais je pense que des
excuses s'imposent et on a également
soulevé la relation entre la couronne et
les autochtones alors elle aussi cette
relation là était souvent faite de
Tordre de préjudice mais en même temps
bon ben on ne peut pas refaire le passé
la couronne c'est l'état et l'État n'est
pas parfait c'est bien dit ça je
reconnais votre sagesse Benoit et c'est
elle dites-moi quelle est la suite des
choses à partir de maintenant donc
Charles a fait sa première allocution
son premier discours public mais il y a
chaque jour un calendrier assez précis
prévu peut-être sans entrer dans les
détails nous dire ce qui nous attend au
cours des prochains jours et bien là
j'imagine que le prince le roi Charles
est retourné à Balmoral il va avoir deux
jours où
le cercueil de la reine va être encore
là il va avoir un arrêt à Édimbourg pour
une journée avec une une cérémonie et
ensuite le cercueil va être apporté par
avion et non pas par crainte tel que
c'était prévu
auparavant et il va avoir quatre jours
de chapelle ardent pour permettre au
britanniques et à tous les gens qui
viennent qui viendront de d'autres pays
pour défiler devant
le catafal et ensuite bien il y aura
peut-être une journée entre la fin de la
chapelle ardente et les funérailles pour
permettre à la famille d'avoir une
journée pour se recueillir et ensuite ce
sera les funérailles bon on disait que
tout ça se faisait 10 jours après le
décès mais je serais surprise que les
funérailles aient lieu le 18 puisque le
c'est un dimanche donc j'ai plus
l'impression que les funérailles vont
avoir lieu le 19 et là ça sera la fin du
deuil national mais la famille royale
elle va observer une autre semaine deuil
ou plusieurs activités vont être annulés
ou reportées
dans l'écran la fenêtre en bas de
l'écran on voit dogford le premier
ministre de l'Ontario signé un livre de
recueil de recueillement Estelle juste
une dernière question de l'impression il
est aussi question que Charles fasse une
tournée n'est-ce pas des du Royaume-Uni
oui ce sont dans les prochains jours je
crois même dès demain il va aller en
Écosse il est déjà en Écosse en Irlande
du Nord au Pays de Galles et ensuite il
va revenir là en grande en
Grande-Bretagne à Londres au palais de
Buckingham merci beaucoup Estelle
Boutier Benoît Pelletier merci beaucoup
d'avoir passé la dernière heure et demie
avec nous très apprécié bonne journée à
vous
a prononcé son premier discours public
une première intervention publique
depuis qu'il est devenu roi hier avec la
mort de sa mère Elisabeth II il affirme
s'inscrire dans la continuité de sa mère
avec le sens du devoir de respecter et
de défendre la Constitution c'est-à-dire
la monarchie constitutionnelle c'est
donc sa première journée comme roi et sa
première intervention sur la place
publique merci d'avoir été des nôtres
pour cette émission spéciale bon
après-midi
[Musique]